[Musique]
l'élu d'opposition les républicains à la
verrière nicolas dainville lance sa
campagne pour les municipales avec une
liste sans étiquette trois axes pour son
programme éducation sécurité et qualité
de vie
l'open de france de golf débute jeudi
trois joueurs français engagés dans ce
sens troisième tournoi national benjamin
hebert victor perez et romain langue
ascq et puis l'artiste nicolas sanhes
installe sa dernière réalisation à
trappes
nous étions présents pour découvrir sa
nouvelle oeuvre monumentale et percé ce
secret c'est entouré du président du
conseil départemental et du président de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines que nicolas
dainville a lancé sa campagne pour les
municipales 2020 à la verrière
conseiller d'opposition les républicains
sa liste pour ce scrutin sera pourtant
sans étiquette
elle regroupe des sensibilités
différentes avec un objectif faire
bouger les choses à la verrière on a
envie d'améliorer là la sécurité une
ville plus sûre avec une police
municipale plus nombreuses on a envie
d'agir dans nos écoles avec les outils
les plus innovants pour permettre la
réussite de chaque enfant
on a envie d'agir sur la qualité de vie
avec notamment un aménagement des
bécanes qui soit mesuré qui respecte cet
esprit village et qui permettent à pas
tous les habitants de vivre ensemble
dans une ville de tuile dont ils soient
fiers sa campagne reposera donc sur ces
trois piliers nicolas d'un ville
souhaite également collaboré avec saint
quentin en yvelines le département ou la
région pour le financement par exemple
de certains projets comme la rénovation
du quartier du bois de l'étang
moi mon projet c'est effectivement un
projet de rénovation sans démolition en
mobilisant des fonds les fonds européens
les fonds liés à l'agglomération les
fonds liés au département les fonds
peuvent mobiliser les bailleurs comme ça
ça poissy comme ça se fait et long cours
avec les petits prés donc il ya des
possibilités pour ses prochaines
élections municipales nicolas dainville
devra faire face notamment à la maire
sortante nelly duthu le rêve de nombreux
parents depuis septembre dernier micro
crèche est ouverte à la gare be enough
le pontchartrain sur la ligne n
la structure privée permet d'accueillir
dix enfants de moins de 3 ans dont les
parents sont usagers des transports les
collaborations entre la région ile de
france et la sncf
oui c'est un service qu'on apporte à nos
voyageurs du quotidien qui ont toujours
des problèmes bien évidemment pour se
déplacer et avec leurs enfants le matin
pour les déposer dans un lieu une crèche
une crèche familiale et donc on
considère que c'est un bon service qu'on
apporte à nos voyageurs du quotidien
ça complète l'offre on a on a déjà une
crèche intercommunale avec joueurs pros
chartrain et neauphle le château dans
laquelle nous avons 13 berceau
transversaux ça fait un équivalent vingt
familles donc est donc cette crèche va
compléter naturellement la structure de
148 mètres carrés fonctionnera comme une
crèche classique entre deux et quatre
encadrants s'occupe des enfants pendant
la journée et parfois plus en cas
d'imprévu sur les rails
on peut imaginer un train en retard mal
à personne et plus assurés de pouvoir
récupérer ses enfants de manière voilà
comme le train du choix sont arrivés en
retard le personnel de la crèche peu
voilà être avoir une indulgence qu'on
n'a pas forcément ailleurs dans les
autres régimes
coût total de l'opération 500 mille
euros d'ici 2024 20 projets petite
enfance devrait ouvrir sur le même
modèle en ile de france
l'albatros est prêt pour accueillir le
103e open de france de golf de
l'histoire la compétition est organisée
de ce jeudi 17 à ce dimanche 20 octobre
au golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines une date
inhabituelle pour un événement programmé
ces dernières années fin juin mais cet
open automnale ne semble pas perturber
l'organisation où je serai pas aussi
positif si j'avais des doutes mais non
le style jean glace la façon dont
laquelle ses montées c'est très bien on
a l'impression d'être sur un tournoi en
tout cas et
le plateau de joueurs et pas mal le
plateau de joueurs sera notamment
composé du danois thomasg en capitaines
de la ryder cup 2018 à saint quentin en
yvelines
les meilleurs golfeurs français seront
également présents sur le parcours de
l'albatros avec notamment victor perez
dernier français vainqueur sur
l'european tour
le joueur de 27 ans numéro un français
sera le chef de file de la délégation
comme mon objectif cette semaine
forcément de de performer au mieux
d'essayer de le prendre comme n'importe
quelle semaine même si forcément c'est
difficile d'être en france et voilà
après c'est de me concentrer sur le jeu
je connais le parcours ce qui est un
avantage
autre star de cette édition le parcours
avec les 18 trous de l'albatros
comme toutes les années devrait donner
des sueurs froides aux meilleurs il a
juste comme il faut il est là sélectif
mine de rien et franchement il est en
super condition c'est un des meilleurs
parcours de l'année dont quatre blessés
c'est dur de ne pas être content d'être
là l'open de france de golf se terminera
ce dimanche soir avec peut-être une
victoire française la première depuis
2011 et un certain thomas levet on
fouille on farfouille au festival de la
bande dessinée de buc les amoureux ne
peuvent s'empêcher et parfois trouver
les trésors en charge pépites et surtout
celle là où ça monsieur était passionné
qui
a monté sa propre voix des petits
fascicules comme ça à tonnerre de bulles
un book un bouquet leurs books est un
élégant qu'un dessinateur écrivain
magnifique et du coup je les trouvais
chez lui et c'est pour ça d'ailleurs
mais le festival c'est avant tout un
moment de rencontres avec les auteurs et
illustrateurs près d'une cinquantaine de
professionnels ont fait le déplacement
cette année ça fait un peu partie du
travail de
de se prêter au jeu de la promotion
pendant un certain temps surtout dans
l'album est fraîchement sorti quelques
mois belge bien voir marc védrines du
coup mais c'est pas pour moi c'est pour
quelqu'un d'autre moi j'ai pas grandi
dans cette culture de bd parce que
je suis allemand
il n'y a pas trop ça mais mon mari il
aime beaucoup les bd
les enfants aussi du coup je suis ravi
super choix la jeunesse n'est pas mise
de côté au milieu des passionnés des
enfants qui ne peuvent s'empêcher
d'aller voir leurs créateurs préférés et
rock vos torts des profs
chaque fois c'est amusant et j'aime bien
ces personnages ça ça nous rappelle le
collège et les auteurs qu'on voit ça
nous rappelle les professeurs et j'ai
quand même une série qui commence à voir
quelques années mais j'ai des nouveaux
lecteurs donc des enfants ça ça fait
plaisir parce que
le risque c'est que les électeurs vis en
même temps que les auteurs et les séries
de bd
une affluence record de la part des
bédéphiles cette année a vu plus de huit
mille passionnés ont cherché à rapporter
un souvenir personnalisé
ce rond point que tout le monde appelle
la place au val a désormais une identité
nicolas sagne a réalisé une sculpture
d'une tonne 7
elle est installée rue maryse bastié ce
sont les trois lignes d'accès tout son
mari d'entre elles normalement elles
sont blanches il faudra lever la lamal
agenais seront blanches
c'est une sculpture qui parle d' espace
ma sculpture ce genre de ce style
d'assemblage on va dire de ligne 2 qui
frappe 21 15 éléments c'est selon c'est
le fais mon travail c'est ma marque de
fabrique
originaire de rodez nicolas sagna fait
le choix il y a un nom d'habiter trappe
suite à une demande du conseil municipal
de la ville l'artiste a conçu cette
pièce en quatre mois avec les
contraintes liées à l'aménagement urbain
si on arrive à sculpture l'ascum ouvert
en réalité la m que la masse car côté
réseau des réseaux électriques des
réseaux de gaz des réseaux seul espace
urbain l'aménagement urbain les belles
de la ville qui passe de sous
cette place est à la jonction du
quartier dit de l'aéro stats et de celui
des merisiers l'endroit retenu pour
commémorer la mémoire d'arnaud beltrame
officier supérieur de la gendarmerie qui
s'était volontairement substituer à une
tâche cours de l' attaque terroriste de
mars 2018 à trail
nous voulions rendre hommage à monsieur
beltrame
pour l'ate très presque surhumain qu'il
a accompli finalement de se laisser
assassiner à la place dans une personne
qui n'avait pas les fonctions des
responsabilités qu'il assume et on
pouvait pas laisser passer ça sans
marquer le souvenir
l'oeuvre de nicolas sanhes mesure 2
mètres 50 par trois mètres l'artiste est
ravie d'animer ce rond point rue maryse
bastié au printemps chez libre et
insultants à rodez ville de naissance
et si je les vends une sculpture mal de
coeur sur la main
donc c'est une très belle année je suis
ravi que mon travail soit accepté
prochainement des bulbes rouge de
tulipes vont être plantés autour de la
sculpture
[Musique]
cette semaine dans les salles de
l'espace philippe noiret de la ville les
clayes-sous-bois nous avons un avant
goût des vacances scolaires avec en
sortie nationale
la deuxième aventure de shaun le mouton
ou la ferme contre attaque
l'avant première du film abominable et
le fameux film culte de steven spielberg
ready playerone que nous vous proposons
en ciné débat le mardi 22 octobre à
16h30 dans le cadre de la semaine de la
parentalité
nous vous proposons également à lisser
le maire à mettant en scène fabrice
luccini et anis démons anaïs démons
thiais et également nous vous invitons
de venir voir le film donne moi des
ailes de nicolas vanier une aventure
palpitante et merveilleuse que vous fera
traverser les cieux et les mers du nord
en ulm aux côtés de jean paul rouve
mélanie doutey pluie wacquez et bien sûr
des oies sauvages
vous pourrez retrouver ce film la
semaine suivante en compagnie de joker
jay minimale terminator fine ou encore
angry birds
[Musique]